now over three million men from the
Commonwealth served in the First World
War one and a half million came from pre
partition India 74 thousand of them lost
their lives and 11 were awarded the
Victoria Cross well early this morning
wreaths were laid at the Delhi War
Memorial and among those taking part in
a ceremony was the chair of the Foreign
Affairs Select Committee and the former
Army officer Tom ticket who joins us
hello thank you for being with us this
morning good morning Sophie how are you
I'm all right thank you I'm good now I
just mentioned in the introduction to
your interview that 1.5 million men from
South Asia signed up to the British Army
in World War one which is an incredible
number of people really who Muslims
Sikhs Hindus do you think we do enough
to remember their sacrifice no I don't
think we do enough and we've got to
remember these men who came from every
village from every community in the then
undivided India communities that are now
of course in India and Pakistan and
Bangladesh and Sri Lanka came as
volunteers they volunteered like other
people who joined our armed forces in
those days they joined out of a sense of
duty out of a sense of honour and and of
course you know it's but young men for
the spirit of adventure and very much
the similar reasons that people join our
armed forces today and so I think it's
right that we do much more to remember
them and remember that at moments like
the very early days in 1914 it was the
Indians who held the line when the
Germans that he broke through to cut off
the Channel ports they actually say
these are men who volunteered and and
yet they were under colonial rule do you
think the government should apologise to
Commonwealth leaders for some of the
wrongs of the past well I certainly
think we should apologize for some of
the wrongs that happen and Prime
Minister David Cameron did apologize for
some of the wrongs that happened but for
all of us it's important to recognize
that there were wrongs but it's there's
also a lot that we've done together and
it's impossible today to talk about
British history without speaking of
India and it's impossible today to speak
of Indian history without speaking of
Britain you know we really are two
countries that have
grown-ups together over the past two
centuries and I think it's very
important that we remember that we wrote
the stories together and with
cooperation we can help shape the future
together as well talking about shaping
that future do you think there is an
opportunity with breath set to reshape
relationships with being kind I
absolutely do I think it's extremely
important that we used this moment to
look hard at our relationships around
the world and none more so than our
relationship with India but I've been
struck over the few days that I've been
here at the warmth of the reception that
I've received from members of parliament
from civic society from people from all
walks of life and the proximity of our
relationship now we don't agree on
everything that would be too much to
expect with any country but we have a
very very deep common understanding of
the world as we see it we share very
strongly common values we share the
values of the rule of law of democracy
of a free press that are not found in as
many countries as we would like and
certainly here in the indo-pacific
region are absolutely vital to our
future and so I look forward I hope to
working very much more closely with the
people of India at every level now
yesterday Donald Trump missed a visit to
a war cemetery because of bad weather
and I just want to read you what cynical
assumes the Conservative MP in the
ground some of Winston Churchill said
about that he said they died with their
face to the phone and that pathetic
inadequate Donald Trump couldn't even
defy the weather to pay his respects to
the fallen he's not fit to represent
this great country do you agree well
I'll leave Nicholas to speak for himself
but he has a certain way with words all
I'll say is I spent four years in
Afghanistan and I don't remember
operations being canceled when it rained
I don't remember them being canceled for
the Col I don't remember us not refusing
to soldier because the weather was
inclement I seem to remember that in
Iraq and Afghanistan when sometimes it
was minus 15 and sometimes it was 50
degrees in the shade we sold it on how
does your experience in Iraq and
Afghanistan shape the politics because
you've spoken about you know some pretty
horrific things that happened a suicide
bomber for example blown themselves up
in there
courtyard of your office in Helmand I
mean this must have been an incredibly
shaping its Varun's view okay all of us
who've served have had the privilege of
meeting some of the most impressive men
and women that you'll ever likely to
meet and for me that's what shaped my
politics it's that sense of duty that I
have to our country and to the people
who've given so much you know and it's
recognizing that I mean Sophie I I've
been blessed but come from an incredibly
strong and loving family and I've been
had the good fortune of economic
stability
all my life now I know that many of the
men and women I had the privilege to
serve with did not have that and what
I've got to do is to try and make sure
as a politician that the benefits of our
society that the good things in our
society has spread as widely as possible
and that's exactly what I'm trying to do
through the politics that I now practice
now that's where for me this is a
continuation of a sense of duty let's
talk about that sense of duty you said
of your time in the Army in Iraq I was
one of many soldiers who questioned the
decision but obeyed the orders and I
just wonder if that will be you know go
take on brexit as well and how are you
feeling about the deal that Theresa May
is currently fighting for is that
something that you can support well it's
very hard to know what the deal is I'm
afraid I unlike the two or perhaps three
people who are really in the room
negotiating I'm afraid none of us
actually know what the prime minister is
going to bring forward so until I know
what the details are I find it very
difficult to comment I'm just commenting
in the dark and that's why I have been
very careful not to say too much on it
because I just be guessing and what the
people deserve now you know people of
our country deserve now is not more
guesses from politicians as to what the
future might hold but serious considered
thought as to what the options are
before us we've got a pretty good idea
that haven't we of the kind of thing
that Theresa May is looking at
particularly with regards to the
backstop the whole of the UK staying in
a customs union with the European Union
in an effective customs union Oh Joe
Johnson your colleague resigned this
week and he said that there's been a
failure of British statecraft
on a scale on theme' since the Suez
Crisis
is he right well Joe again has his own
ways of expressing things and there
isn't a Johnson in the land who doesn't
have a particularly colorful way of
making their point clear so I'll leave
him to speak for himself but I think
it's again I'm friend I'm gonna be
difficult in now on this because I don't
know what the Prime Minister has got as
the final negotiations and what the back
spot does of course matter the idea of
the backstop is that it never is used so
depending on what the Prime Minister
brings forward I will then know whether
or not the backstop is important or not
so I'm waiting now to hear what the
Prime Minister has to say and Joe is
right in that this is an extremely
important moment for the United Kingdom
this is a moment when we have decided to
reset the relationship for the first
time in 40 years to really change the
strategy of the United Kingdom from one
a proximity trade to one of remoter
trade and now that's that's a really big
call but we did discuss this for quite a
long time before the referendum in 2016
this was a topic of much discussion
around the country as we all remember
and many of us were very clear in the
way that we considered it best to to
speak about the questions and I had
these debates in 2015 and I had them in
2016 and so that I'm afraid this isn't a
huge surprise to me that the questions
now before us are very difficult okay I
can see that you're not going to be too
drawn on brexit and you've previously
said that after breaks it's time for a
generational shift in the Conservative
Party what did you mean by that
well what I meant by that is I've got a
huge privilege to sit alongside some
really impressive guys on on the
conservative benches you know people
like Vickie Atkins who's in the home
office at the moment is really one of
the brightest and most able people of
our generation Kip bobhouse who's doing
amazing things with housing and doing it
completely brilliantly remembering the
sense of place and identity that we all
need in
in it and then of course you know I can
run through people like James cleverly
and Johnny Mercer and so on who who
really have fantastic ways of expressing
and communicating so whether it's you
know whether it's that generation of
Rishi's tunic and Lucy Fraser or whether
it's another generation just after us of
people like Palmerston I just think
they're ahead of an opportunity on the
conservative benches to really have some
serious impact on some serious ideas to
take the country forward and someone
said to me that the list of people who
aren't running for the Conservative
Party leadership will end up being
longer than the list of people who are
running for the Conservative Party
leader yeah exactly and I wonder if it's
something that you'd consider putting
your name ahead at the moment I'm just
waiting to see what the deal the Prime
Minister brings back I mean I haven't
made any great secret of the fact that I
would I would consider running from my
party leadership at some point but for
me the whole point of this is not to run
for the leadership is to change the
country for me the whole point of this
is not to be an individual to be a team
you know if one thing the soldiering
taught me is that individuals we don't
achieve very much but we have an amazing
conservative team you know I've listed
some names there and there are many
others and if we get the right people in
the team then actually the leadership
becomes not academic but certainly only
only an expression of that and that's
what we've got to get to we've got to
get a really strong conservative team
forward arguing for the future of the
country arguing for a positive future
arguing for a future that includes
everybody in our community and really
values the work that so many do and you
know from the young to the old you know
we have an amazingly dynamic society
sometimes I think we forget that and and
it's a great shame because it leads us
to despondency where when actually we
should be fully optimistic and so I'm
really focused on bringing you know
doing my bit to support a conservative
team and see where that gets us it's
interesting to listen to you talking
about the future there and the concepts
have been in power for eight years do
you sometimes worry that the new current
administration the current form of the
Conservative Party is a bit tired a
little bit consumed by brexit well I
think it's the nature of any major
struggle that it consumes those who are
engaged in it I mean we know this
whether you look at a merger
an acquisition or any sort of you know
major operation and military or whatever
it it you always find that those who
have really focused in on it who really
had to do nothing but that for a long
period of time tend to get a bit worn
out not hardly surprising but it's it's
a credit to those who are engaged in the
debate at the moment that they are
devoting every inch of energy every
every moment of energy in order to to
try and bring forward the best outcome
for the British people and I think
that's that's absolutely right now once
that is done will people look for a
change I suspect they will and I think
it's it's for the Conservative Party to
come forward and be that change and I
think we can be I think we have an
amazing opportunity as I've listed
already you know from the from the
number of people and ideas on our
benefit to come forward and make a
fantastic change and bring the country
forward
ok Tonto you can have thank you